this morning President Trump says anyone
doing business with Iran will not be
doing business with the United States
that tweet follows a presidential order
reimposing sanctions that the Obama
administration suspended under a
multinational nuclear deal with Iran the
US would drew from that agreement in May
we did Jang is near the president's New
Jersey Golf Club where he is on vacation
we Joe good morning good morning Vlad
the White House says the move is meant
to change the regime's behavior and not
to take down leaders in Tehran the
sanctions target Iran's gold and metal
industries as well as its auto sector
they also restrict Iran from using US
dollars in financial transactions in a
statement President Trump warned of
severe consequences for those who
continued business with Iran in a joint
statement European foreign minister said
they deeply regret the sanctions and are
taking measures to protect EU companies
doing legitimate business with Iran the
allies have maintained and remained
committed to the 2015 agreement last
week President Trump offered to meet
with Iranian president Hassan rouhani
with no preconditions
but yesterday rouhani called
negotiations while under sanctions
meaningless saying if someone has a
knife in one hand and seeks talks he
should first put the knife in his pocket
a second set of sanctions targeting
Iran's banking sector and oil industry
go into effect in November and the Trump
administration says it will consider
case-by-case requests for exemptions
Gael all right we sure got it thank you
very much